JAMES GRIME: One, two, three,
test, test, test.
BRADY HARAN: You know
that's not your--
JAMES GRIME: OK.
Hello everyone, how
are you doing?
OK, so today, we're not going to
do a number by itself, but
a number that comes
with a friend--
220 and 284.
These are called amicable
numbers, or friendly numbers.
OK, so why are two
numbers friends?
Well, we're going to look at the
divisors of these numbers.
So what divides 220?
Well, 1 divides 220.
2, 4, 5, 10, 11, 20, 22, 44, 55,
110, and 220 itself, but
we don't include 220 itself,
not the number itself.
So we take these numbers here.
And if we add them up, we're
going to get 284.
But if we do the same thing
for 284, what divides 284?
1, 2, 4, 71 divides, and 142.
If we take those numbers and
add them up, we get 220.
So the divisors of 284 add up
to 220, and the divisors of
220 make 284.
So they come as a pair.
That's friendly.
For mathematicians,
that's friendly.
These aren't the only numbers,
but this is the smallest pair
of numbers that do this.
Now, these numbers were known in
ancient times, and in those
days, they liked to give
numbers properties.
And these numbers would
represent perfect harmony,
mutual friendship, and love.
So two lovers would inscribe
220 and 284 on talismans.
And you would wear one talisman,
and you would give
the other to your lover, a story
I like so much, I even
had 220 and 284 inscribed
on talismans of my own.
BRADY HARAN: Why have you
got both of them?
Shouldn't your lover have
the other half?
JAMES GRIME: Yeah, thanks
for pointing that out.
Thanks for bringing that up.
I'm a 220 still looking
for my 284.
So these were known
in ancient times.
A few more were know
after that.
Actually, in the 17th century,
it was the 17th century
mathematicians who started to
look for some more of these.
But what I like about this is
that they missed a pair.
In fact, they missed the
second smallest pair of
amicable numbers.
And these were found 200 years
later in the 19th century by a
16-year-old Italian schoolboy
who found the second smallest
pair of amicable numbers, which
are about 1,184 and--
you can work the other
one out for yourself.
However, their best use is
probably their original one
when two lovers would inscribe
the numbers 220 and 284 to two
halves of a fruit.
And then they would split the
fruit, and you take one half
for yourself, one half for your
lover, and by consuming
the fruit, you become
complete.
BRADY HARAN: Awww!
That's lovely.
I've got an apple out
here somewhere.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Oh, it's
got a hole in it.
BRADY HARAN: That'll do.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Is
that all right?
BRADY HARAN: Yep.
JAMES GRIME: Do the same thing
for 284, and you'll get 220.
BRADY HARAN: Don't cut
yourself, by the way.
JAMES GRIME: 220, can you see?
BRADY HARAN: Oh,
yeah, sort of.
JAMES GRIME: 284.
220 and 284, just about.
Who am I going to give
the other half to?
[LAUGHTER]
BRADY HARAN: No one's
taking it.
[LAUGHTER]